les agriculteurs qui possède un sol en
santé qui nécessite moins d'engrais
seront vraiment gagnant cette année
parce que depuis un an le prix des
matières fertilisantes a explosé l'azoté
le phosphore le potassium tous les
minéraux essentiels à la croissance des
plantes enregistrent des hausses
vertigineuses dépassant 200 % dans
certains cas mais pourquoi l'engrais et
il soudainement si cher
pour fabriquer de l'engrais il faut
énormément d'énergie fossile la vigueur
des prix du pétrole et du gaz naturel
tire donc le coût des fertilisants vers
le haut mais il ya plus aux etats unis
le passage de l'ouragan ida au mois
d'août a forcé certains grands complexes
chimiques à suspendre leurs opérations
les problèmes logistiques de main
d'oeuvre et de transport liées à la cage
vide ont aussi contribué à créer de la
rareté des facteurs géopolitiques
expliquerait également la flambée des
prix la chine l'un des plus importants
producteurs mondiaux d'engrais a fait
face à des pénuries d'électricité ce qui
a entraîné la mise à l'arrêt de milliers
d' usine tout comme la russie autre gros
joueur mondial la chine resterait ses
exportations d'engrais pour
approvisionner son marché national en
priorité il faut tout de même préciser
qu'en amérique du nord le marché des
engrais est dominé par quelques
entreprises seulement pour s'assurer que
celles-ci ne profite pas de la situation
pour s'enrichir à l'excès l'union
nationale des fermiers a demandé au
gouvernement fédéral d'ouvrir une
enquête sur le prix des engrais au
canada
en attendant tout cela signifie qu'il en
coûtera plus cher aux agriculteurs cette
année pour faire pousser un hectare de
maïs par exemple et au final cette
facture risque fort de se refléter sur
notre facture d'épicerie